[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo liebe Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer und
willkommen zu einer neuen Ausgabe
unseres täglichen True Crime Podcasts
Tatort Deutschland mein Name ist Mirko
Kasimir und ich bin Natalie Strauß moin
wir erzählen euch heute einen Fall der
auch im Nachhinein nur schwer zu
verstehen ist ein Fall in dem vieles
nicht ist wie es scheint dieser
vierfache Mord erschütterte Deutschland
im Jahr 2009 für die Polizei begann der
Fall am Morgen des 10 April es war
Karfreitag
[Musik]
nach einem Notruf fahren Beamte zu einem
Einfamilienhaus in der Friedhofstraße 89
im baden-württembergischen Eislingen als
sie dort eintreffen sitzen der
18-Jährige Andreas H und sein
19-jähriger Kumpel Frederik B völlig
erschüttert vor dem Eingang im Haus von
Andreas Familie finden die Polizisten
die Leichen seiner beiden Schwestern und
der älter alle wurden erschossen Andreas
Gesicht so berichtet später die
Süddeutsche Zeitung ist nass von Tränen
er schreit seine Verzweiflung heraus und
schwirrt die Mörder seiner Familie zur
Rechenschaft zu ziehen ich bringe die um
die das getan haben ruft er die Polizei
geht derweil ihrer Arbeit nach das heißt
die Spurensicherung stellt das Haus auf
den Kopf macht Fotos nimmt Abdrücke
vermisst Blutspuren und sammelt
Gegenstände und Fasern ein die Kollegen
nehmen derweil Andreas und friederik mit
auf die Wache und lassen sich alles noch
einmal Haar klein erzählen und
eigentlich kann der zentrale Punkt sehr
bald nach der Tat geklärt werden die
Geschichte der beiden Haut einfach nicht
hin Andreas und Frederick wollen erst am
Morgen am Haus eingetroffen sein und die
Leichen entdeckt haben aber ihr
Verhalten kommt dem von jemand ganz
schnell merkwürdig vor und vor allem es
finden sich Schmauchspuren bei Ihnen
außerdem gab es keinerlei Einbruchspuren
im Haus und die Lage der Toten ließ
darauf schließen dass ihre Mörder Kanten
und keinen Widerstand leisteten
acht Tage nach dem Fund der Leichen
gesteht friederika den Mord an der
Familie seines Freundes Andreas er führt
die Polizei auch zum Versteck der
Tatwaffen in dieser ersten Phase sieht
es für die Polizei und die
Öffentlichkeit so aus Andreas und
Frederick haben die Tat geplant weil der
Sohn an das Vermögen des Vaters wollte
und Frederik war der der diese dann mit
der Waffe ausführte aber erstens sollte
sich das mit dem Motiv als komplizierte
herausstellen zweitens war später auch
der Tatablauf umstritten und es geht
noch zu klären was ist mit einem Code
auf sich hatte einem Geheimcode der
5142 lautete und wie Natalie schon sagte
hier ist einiges nicht wie es scheint
dieser Fall fängt also gerade erst an
ich will an dieser Stelle mal eine
krasse Zahl erwähnen 70% aller
Tötungsdelikte kommen innerhalb von
Familien vor das heißt du schwebst
eigentlich in größter Lebensgefahr wenn
du von deinen Liebsten umgeben bist wie
abgefahren ist das denn und in unserem
heutigen Fall ist das Familienidyll
marcellos in Eislingen bei Göppingen
gilt Familie h als Inbegriff eines
vorbildlichen Lebens Vater Hans-jürgen
ist Heilpraktiker die Praxis liegt im
Erdgeschoss des Hauses seine Frau else
arbeitet als Englischlehrerin Freunde
beschrieben sie als hübsche fröhliche
Person Ihr Garten ist ihr ganzer Stolz
täglich gießt sie die Blumen auch die
beiden erwachsenen Töchter wollen
Lehrerin werden das an Christin 24 Jahre
alt Spitzname Chrissi sie studiert
Pädagogik in Schwäbisch Gmünd genau wie
ihre Mutter früher sie hat ein Freund
namens Gustavo und die beiden leben
gemeinsam in ihre eigenen Wohnung
Annemarie 22 Spitzname Mimi studiert
ebenfalls Pädagogik an der gleichen Uni
hat auch einen Freund wohnt aber noch zu
Hause Sohn Andreas 18 macht erst den
Realschulabschluss geht dann mit guten
Noten auf ein Wirtschaftsgym Museum er
gilt unter Mitschülern als Sunnyboy
kommt bei Mädchen gut an
letzten Sommer pilgert er dann den
Jakobsweg nach Santiago de Compostela
hielt darüber einen Diavortrag kurz
gefasst von außen ist das die letzte
Familie die man mit Straftaten oder gar
Mord in Verbindung bringt alle stehen
auf jeder Ebene mitten im Leben Mutter
else singt im Kirchenchor Andreas
engagiert sich bei den
Rettungsschwimmern von DLRG und ist
Schulsprecher an der Realschule die
Töchter führen die Hunde Alter Damen aus
oder organisieren in Kneipenquiz es ist
fast schon zu perfekt von Hans-Jürgen
erzählt man sich er sei ein liebevoller
Vater der seine drei Kinder alle gleich
behandle die Familie verschickt jedes
Jahr Weihnachts Postkarten mit
Botschaften wie mit unseren Kindern sind
wir sehr gesegnet alle sind gesund und
machen uns viel Freude da haben wir also
unser perfektes Öl und wenn es darin
Risse oder Untiefen gibt bekommt das von
außen so schnell keiner mit aber für
Andreas führt sich das alles nicht so
toll an wie es wirkt immerhin kann er
sich bei seinem Mitschüler Frederick aus
dem Gymnasium das Herz ausschütten und
der war absolut kein Sunnyboy sondern
eher scheu er galt in der Grundschule
als Außenseiter und hatte keine Freunde
ihm wird den Prozess später das
Asperger-Syndrom attestiert eine Form
des Autismus den Andreas Haff findet
Frederik eine Art lebensmenschen und
erfährt so auch dass nicht alles Gold
ist was bei dessen Muster Familie so
glänzt zum Beispiel Andreas 18
Geburtstag wie die Süddeutsche Zeitung
später rekonstruierte schenkt ihm Vater
Hans-jürgen an dem Tag eine schöne Uhr
und will mit dem jetzt erwachsenen Sohn
ein Bordellbesuchen eine Idee die
Andreas total absurd und demütigen
findet Vater und Sohn fahren Schweigen
nach Hause und überhaupt zwischen Vater
und Sohn da kracht es öfter bei einer
Winterwanderung im All wird die Familie
von einem Unwetter überrascht
Hans-jürgen treibt seine Familie
lautstark zum Weitermachen an Sohn
Andreas findet das fahrlässig aber weder
seine Mutter noch die beiden Schwestern
unterstützen ihn sein Vater wird er
später sagen sei allen Türen gewesen und
er fühlte sich allein gelassen in dieser
Zeit reift ein teuflischer Plan
was wenn wir die Familie aus dem Weg
räumen denken sich Andreas und sein
Lebensmensch Frederik zu ihren
Vorbereitungen gehört ein Einbruch die
beiden klauen im Schützenverein dem sie
auch angehören 19 Schusswaffen am Anfang
ist noch nicht klar ob der Plan ernst
oder nur eine Art Scherz zwischen den
beiden ist sie geben dem Vorhaben einen
geheimcout 5 1 4 2 die 5 steht für
Andreas fünfköpfige Familie die eins für
friederik 4 für die insgesamt vier
ermordeten und zwei für die Überlebenden
Mörder über Wochen und Monate wird aus
der Spinnerei Ernst wir kommen jetzt zu
dem Abend des 19 April 2009 Hans-jürgen
und Elsa Haas sind zum Essen in eine
Elsinger Gaststätte gegangen die
erwachsenen Töchter Mimi und Chrissi
sind im Haus in der Friedhofstraße 89
und gucken zusammen im Obergeschoss fern
Andreas und Friedrich kommt dazu sie
haben sich vorher im Keller andere
Klamotten angezogen auf die empfohlen
haben sie als Schalldämpfer abgesägte
Colaflaschen gesteckt
Frederick richtet seine Waffe auf die
jungen Frauen was soll der Scheiß ruft
eine von ihnen dann fallen 19 Schüsse
Mimi und Chrissi brechen tot vor dem
Fernseher zusammen der nächste Teil ist
unfassbarkeitblütig die Täter fahren zur
Gaststätte und setzen sich zu den nichts
an den Eltern an den Tisch sie trinken
zusammen unterhalten sich gut gelaunt
und schließlich verabschieden sich die
jungen Männer und kehren zurück in
Andreas Elternhaus
und warten als Vater Hans-jürgen den
Flur betritt und sich die Hausschuhe
anziehen will schießen Andreas H und
Frederik B auf den 57 Jahre alten Vater
und die 55 Jahre alte Mutter Elsa
insgesamt fallen zehn Schüsse das ist so
krass Mirko die haben wohl auf sowas wie
ein Alibi gehofft durch diesen Kneipen
Besuch aber wie eiskalt ist das bitte
mit den Eltern beim Bier rum Scherzen wo
die Schwestern schon tot im Haus liegen
geht's noch ja hast du recht das ist
wirklich schwer zu fassen da gebe ich
dir Recht aber endlich kaltblütig und
verlogen geht es ja auch weiter
Frederick nimmt das Ganze in einem Brief
später die wir haben sie gefunden Show
wir sind jetzt am Morgen des 10 April an
dem Andreas Tränen überströmt vor dem
Haus die Polizei empfängt ein Lehrer
sagt dazu später übrigens laut
Süddeutscher Zeitung Andreas hart seit
der beste Schauspieler gewesen die in es
jemals gegeben habe in der Theatergruppe
der Schule Eislingen das dilettantische
Kneipen Alibi die wir haben sie gefunden
schon die Krokodilstränen nichts davon
geht auf noch nicht einmal 48 Stunden
nach der Tat sitzen Andreas und
Frederick in U-Haft man muss dazu sagen
dass dieser vierfach Mord von Eislingen
wenige Wochen nach dem Amoklauf von
Winnenden passiert Deutschland ist also
schon wieder geschockt von der
unfassbaren Tat junger Männer kein
Wunder also dass der Prozess gegen die
beiden maximale Aufmerksamkeit erfährt
der Prozess beginnt am 12 oktober 2009
vor der sechsten jugendkamer des
Landgerichts Ulm das Gericht hätte die
Öffentlichkeit ausschließen können wenn
dies im Interesse der Angeklagten
geboten gewesen wäre
vergessen entscheidet die Jugendkammer
wegen des großen öffentlichen Interesses
neun namentlich ausgewählte Journalisten
zuzulassen die Staatsanwaltschaft geht
davon aus dass Andreas H seine Familie
aus Habgier tötete weil er das Vermögen
von der Familie Alleinerben wollte
während der Verhandlung legen beide
Angeklagte Eingeständnis ab friederik B
behauptet dabei zunächst alleine die
tödlichen Schüsse abgegeben zu haben
Andreas H hatte die Tat geplant um
seinen Freund überredet sie auszuführen
da er selbst Hemmung hatte aber was das
Motiv angeht zeichnen die Angeklagten
und ihre Verteidiger ein anderes Bild
sie verweisen auf Szenen wie bei der
Bergwanderung im Allgäu und stellen
Vater Hans-jürgen als Tyrannen da der
seinen Sohn Andreas unterdrückt habe im
Prozess geht es auch um das Verhältnis
von Frederick und Andreas sind die
beiden ein cooles Paar gab es deshalb
Stress mit dem Vater ein
vernehmungsbeamter tritt als Zeuge auf
er erklärt dem Richter
Frederick sagte uns dass er und Andreas
2008 bei einem Mallorca-Urlaub mit der
Familie h vom Vater im Bett erwischt
worden sein übrigens ist auch beim
christlichen und offenbar strengen Vater
Hans-jürgen nicht alles wie es scheint
vor seinem Leben als Heilpraktiker hatte
er einen Sexshop und war als Porno Hansi
bekannt allein schon Porno haben sie
komm on na ja aber solche Namen stehen
für eine andere Zeit die 80er das war da
wohl so naja das ist ja auch nur
nebengleist zurück zu Andi und Frederick
ein Gutachter kommt zum Ergebnis dass
sie Freundschaft der beiden zwar
intensiv und von Liebe geprägt war aber
nicht sexueller Natur wichtiger als die
Beziehung ist aber wohl der Tat ergangen
war Frederick wirklich der alleinige
Schütze
die Aussagen im Prozess und die
Vernehmungsprotokolle der Polizei
widersprechen sich hier anders als im
Gerichtssaal hatte Frederik in einem
Verhör gesagt sein Freund Andreas habe
selbst die Schüsse auf Eltern und
Schwestern abgegeben erst als alle
getroffen waren und Andreas war für eine
Ladehemmung hatte soll er zu Frederick
gesagt haben schießt du doch mal
Frederick gestandt dann dass er ein zwei
oder drei Mal auf die sterbende Mutter
geschossen habe übrigens während des
Prozesses vor dem Landgericht Ulm
würdigen sich die beiden einst so eng
befreundeten Schulkameraden keines
Blickes beide tragen Fußfesseln nach 20
Verhandlungstagen das Urteil Andreas
Haar erhält eine lebenslange
Freiheitsstrafe zudem stellen die
Richter die besondere Schwere der
Schulfest
der Täter wird also mehr als 15 Jahre in
Haft verbringen außerdem soll vor einer
möglichen Entlassung geprüft werden ob
er zum Schutz der Allgemeinheit in
Sicherungsverwahrung gehört Friedrich B
verurteilt das Gericht zu einer
Haftstrafe von zehn Jahren nach dem
Jugendstrafrecht zwar will er die
meisten Schüsse abgegeben haben das
Gericht bezweifelt das aber es
berücksichtigt beim Strafmaß auch sein
Asperger-Syndrom bevorsitzende Richter
sagt die jungen Männer haben mit
extremer Gefühlskälte gehandelt die Tat
sei von beiden akribisch geplant worden
man fühlte sich als Herr überleben und
Tod nach allem wie die Familie nach
außen hin gewirkt hatte wäre es
sicherlich unmöglich gewesen diese Tat
Voraus zu ahnen es gab ja nicht diese
typischen Anzeichen die normalerweise
sofort die Alarmglocken schrillen lassen
so wie wir das aus anderen Fällen kennen
die wir hier besprechen dass sie die
Täter im Vorfeld schon auffällig
verhalten und man dadurch vielleicht
hätte ahnen können dass sich dieser Hass
und die Wut irgendwann bahnbrechen
aber diese Tat war keine spontane Tat
aus irgendeinem Impuls heraus es muss
also ein großer Bruch vorgelegen haben
wenn es eine Person dazu treibt die
komplette Familie also auch die Personen
auszulöschen gegen die sich der eigene
Hass ja eigentlich nicht gerichtet hat
ich finde das macht diesem Fall so
unerträglich tja und ganz offenbar hat
Andreas in Frederick dann einen
unheilvollen Verbündeten gefunden ein
idyl das keins war ein vermeintliches
Liebespaar das aber kein schwules Paar
sein wollte ein frommer Heilpraktiker
der mit Pornos gehandelt hat das Leben
kann kompliziert sein es kann sich
jederzeit ändern und auch sehr
trügerisch sein auch in der schwäbischen
Provinz wir danken euch fürs zuhören
wir haben den Fall recherchiert mit
Artikeln aus Bild der FAZ und dem tollen
SZ-Artikel Geheimcode 5142 von Bernd
Doris Aufnahme und schnitt Antonia
Felicitas Heier das Griff hat Stefan
letzte Bank geschrieben Postproduktion
durch Wake world München